à notre arrivée nous avons effectivement
vu une épaisse fumée qui sont retirés
des bâtiments qui pouvait laisser à
penser que si tu te bâtiment qu'ils ont
fait mais lorsque nous avons pu accéder
malgré la difficulté qu'on travaille au
départ nous avons vu que le fait qu'on
te donne une pièce avec beaucoup de
fumée qui effectivement empêche le
progression mais nous avons pu continuer
le sinistre dans la pièce où elle tous
les bâtiments l'un des bâtiments de
médicaments sont actuellement en travaux
pour désamiantage donc la miotte vous
savez c'est comme un jeu dangereux pour
le côlon donc nous pouvons nous il
fallait qu'on entre autres que protéger
pour ne pas avoir eu de problème
particulier et nous avons également fait
de vos connaissances plus apte au niveau
de l'hôpital et de vous dévoiler pour
voir s'il n'y a pas de fumée qui pouvait
les échos maudit